let's talk about the mistakes within a
minute fasting that can really affect
your results number one and you're going
too fast
fasting and your body has not adapted
yet some people like to jump right in
and sometimes you can just go too fast
so let's say for example you just start
out and you've been doing the standard
American diet for years and now you're
gonna start fasting so you're doing this
on top of a blood sugar issue and you
haven't given it the normal three days
to adapt you jump from zero to 90 miles
an hour so you're right at one meal a
day typically what's gonna happen is
you're gonna be very highly irritated
you're gonna be extremely hungry and
you're probably gonna cheat and then
you're gonna say you know this isn't
right for me and give up when in fact if
you did it correctly at the right level
you'll work with the body and it would
work for you all right next one is
you're eating too many carbs without
even realizing that you're eating too
many carbs so sometimes this is called
sorta keto because when I talk to people
they'll tell me that I'm doing the
ketogenic diet and sometimes they'll
tell me it's not working and then I'll
ask them what they're eating and then
they didn't really realize that fruits
are carbohydrates or rice is a
carbohydrate or are sweet potatoes are
carbohydrates they don't realize the
impact that just a little bit of carbs
can have on your ability to stay in
ketosis a little bit of carb can knock
you out for two sometimes even three
days and I'm talking about knocking you
out of ketosis it takes a while to get
into ketosis and all it takes is a
little carb to knock you out
if you're doing this a couple times a
week it could be the reason why you're
not seeing any results
alright the five and to plan okay and
this plan you're pretty much eating
whatever you want for five days okay and
then in two days usually the weekend
you're bringing your calories down to
500 calories per day now the problem is
twofold one is all week long you're
pretty much eating what you want and
then in the weekend you're gonna eat a
smaller meal this is not enough time to
fully adapt to the state of ketosis
you're going to be struggling with this
it's going to be very painful
it's not gonna be comfortable you're not
gonna want to do it and of course you're
gonna probably cheat and say this is not
right for me and give up so if you're
gonna fast I would recommend actually
fasting not try to do this with 500
calories and think you're really gonna
adapt it's just not gonna work all right
number four you're doing fasting but
when you're eating you're not having
enough calories to provide enough
nutrients now here's the thing when
you're actually lowering your calories
you're gonna have to at the same time
increase the nutrient density of that
food or enhance it with other
supplements to make sure you're getting
your nutrients because the purpose of
food is twofold one is fuel the other is
nutrients so when you're fasting you're
tapping into your fat fuel but at some
point you need nutrients so if you're
not consuming enough calories usually
you're not gonna have the nutrients not
first nothing's gonna happen but down
the road let's say some weeks or even
months all of a sudden your hair is
falling out you're noticing other
problems with your teeth are loose
bleeding gums all sorts of things so I
really wouldn't necessarily worry about
calories but really focus on getting
your foods nutrient-dense all right
number five consuming low-quality
ingredients so let's say you're fasting
and then when you eat you're consuming
this powdered soy protein isolate
mixture okay that is very very low
quality and it's in a lot of different
products what's gonna happen with those
low quality ingredients is you're not
gonna look healthy now I'm not saying
that you're gonna completely look like a
crack head but you may sort of look like
a crack head all right next one is
number six you're not consuming enough
potassium and B vitamins and even trace
minerals to make sure your body has all
the requirements now think about this
we're doing fascinating to improve our
health so all sorts of genes are kicking
in anti-aging genes genes that help
reduce inflammation that help her grow
your brain tissue and if you don't have
the reserve of nutrients and you're
fasting and then when you eat you're
consuming regular foods you may end up
being deficient and run into
issues other than looking like a
crackhead heart palpitations hair
falling out you're gonna be totally fun
alright number seven if you're vegan and
you're doing keto make sure you take b12
DHA zinc and probably iron as well
simply because you're not going to get
these unless you consume animal products
alright number eight you're doing it um
in fasting and then when you eat you're
doing keto but you're doing it low fat
some people still have this fat phobia
and they're gonna keep their fats really
really low so if you keep your carbs low
and keep your fats low something has to
go up and that's going to be protein so
too much protein can create problems as
well so when you cut fats you're also
going to cut fat soluble vitamins you're
gonna cut omega-3 fatty acids all sorts
of very essential things with your fat
alright guys thanks for watching
and check out this next video on other
keto mistakes that a lot of people make
but they're not realizing that they're
making them